[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
good evening
easy
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
it requires compromise
and a balancing of competing legitimate
interests that is usually painful and
sometimes feels impossible
decisions are often a
51-49 caller and about choosing between
different Shades of Gray
but every once in a while
a leader faces a black and white choice
a choice of utter moral clarity
and sometimes
accustomed as we are to operating in a
world of ambiguity
leaders of democracies can be slow to
see that the issue before them is indeed
a clear-cut contest between right and
wrong
Russia's invasion of Ukraine is such a
contest it is today's great fight
between light
and darkness
one of the leaders who understood that
seemest
and who has been most resolute
is our prime minister prime minister
Justin Trudeau
[Applause]
a few days after Putin's tanks rolled
across the Ukrainian border I was in a
meeting with the prime minister
now that was a time when Russian
Assassins were roaming the streets of
cave and the threat to the lives of
Ukraine's leaders seemed immediate they
often
at the beginning of meetings Ukraine's
leaders said I hope you'll see me
tomorrow
around the world the expert consensus
was that the Ukrainian Capital would
fall in weeks if not days
but in that candid and private
discussion
our prime minister had total certainty
about what would happen
Ukraine would never give up he said
we would see the same Invincible
determination from the people of Ukraine
as the British had displayed during the
Blitz
when Hitler's bombers Reign death from
the sky
he said and this was just a couple of
weeks after the war started that Ukraine
would hold the line
that Ukraine would fight back
and that Ukraine would win
and he was right
[Applause]
because as I think all of us now
recognize
as all of the people of Canada recognize
as all of the people of the Free World
recognize
this is a war
where the stakes are black and white
this is a fight between Good and Evil
and that is why the Prime Minister
committed then right at the beginning
that Canada would never waver
and that is why we are even more
Resolute now after
575 long long days of brutal fighting
we know that Ukraine can
and must
and will win this war
hello
a
this is
Criminal
the Democracy Pacific
is important
since
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the people of Canada
represented by the amazing Canadians
gathered here tonight
to say to the brave people of Ukraine
through their remarkable leader and his
amazing wife Elena who is here with us
too
[Applause]
tonight is our night to say to them
we will keep the faith
we will never abandon you
our determination is absolute
now one of my favorite poems is written
by a Ukrainian poet called Ivan Franco
it's called to the great momento
when President voladimir zelensky made
his first visit to Canada to Toronto in
July of 2019. shortly after his election
I quoted a passage from that poem while
introducing him
here's that Passage
I'm going to translate freely here this
is my own translation not a literary one
let every one of you be ready for the
great moment
each one of us can be the decisive
leader when the consequential moment
comes
we did not know that
in the summer of 2019.
when that consequential moment would
arrive
or quite how consequential it would be
but in the bloody trenches dug into its
famous black Earth
and in the war-torn streets of its proud
and beautiful cities
Ukraine is today facing that most
consequential of moments
that viliki moment
and under President zielinski's decisive
leadership
Millions upon Millions upon millions of
ukrainians have proven themselves worthy
of that moment
but this fight
the fight for democracy
must also be Canada's moment
our prime minister recognized that from
the very beginning
in the conversation I recounted and in
meeting after meeting where I have
watched him rallying the world to
support Ukraine our prime minister has
proven himself ready for our great
moment and in so doing he has allowed
all of us as Canadians to show ourselves
as a country to be ready for that great
moment
and that is why ladies and gentlemenove
it's a huge honor for me to welcome the
prime minister of Canada Justin Trudeau
foreign
thank you Christian for your words and
for the incredible work that you've done
day in and day out to you know direct
our country in the right way but also to
make sure that we are standing up
unequivocally for Ukraine every single
day
[Applause]
before I begin
I know a lot of people have seen the
tragic news out of Coquitlam today I
want to offer my condolences to the
family of the RCMP officer who lost
their life and to the two officers who
were injured we're all wishing you a
fast and full recovery
we will continue to follow the situation
closely
it is so great to be here with you all
tonight
to welcome president volodemir zielinski
and the first lady of Ukraine olena
zelenska
foreign
it is so great to see so many of you
here come from across the country to
celebrate this moment of solidarity I do
want to recognize all the extraordinary
dignitaries in the uh in the front row
here first of all uh Premier Ford uh
Doug it's great to see you here thank
you for standing so strong
in Ukraine
mayor Olivia ciao thank you very much
for standing up for Ukraine I like the
yellow and blue it's very uh appropriate
other Mayors officials ministers members
of parliament members of the Canadian
Armed Forces who are welcoming us here
to their Hall
it is so good to see all of you but it
is mostly so good to see so many strong
Ukrainian Canadians here to stand for
Ukraine
foreign
[Music]
Canadian support comes from all orders
of government from Community groups from
the diaspora all of Canada is United
behind Ukraine
I know that
tonight is a very special group
some of the folks that I visited last
February from Saint demetrius's School
yeah there you are in the back
now Saint Demetrius here in Toronto has
welcomed more than a hundred Ukrainian
children to their classes
fellow students and teachers have
collected books clothes and food to give
to their new friends and Neighbors
and they are extraordinary and they are
wonderful and we need to give them a big
round of applause
but what's great about them is that
they're actually not unique
there are schools like that communities
like that right across the country
opening up their homes their hearts
their communities to people fleeing
horrific situations showing the support
love the solidarity that Canada is so
known for San Francisco is
Canadians have a reputation around the
world for being welcoming friendly open
thank you for demonstrating every single
day that that is absolutely the case
to see bullets and bombs can do a lot of
damage
but one thing they can never take away
is your sense of community
I've seen this sense of community when I
visited Thief even in times of war and
I'm seeing it here in Canada every day
see Canadians and ukrainians have shared
a special bond for a long time
over the past generation so many
Canadians of Ukrainian origin
have helped build our country
and as I've said before it is
right as rain therefore that it be
Canada and Canadians who will be there
helping Ukraine rebuild for future
Generations
[Applause]
Canada stands with Ukraine
and we do so in an absolutely
unequivocal fashion
we do so yes because of the deep ties
and friendships that have bonded our
countries and our peoples
for so long
the contributions of Ukrainian Canadians
that have made this country what it is
today
the Deep connections and Family Ties
that still exist the alignments and
values
countries that believe in each other
we are good friends as countries
but that's not the only reason why we
stand so solidly with Ukraine
we stand with Ukraine because it is the
right thing to do
I don't have to tell anyone here tonight
that the world is a particularly
challenging place these days
whether it's the increasing impacts of
extreme weather events from climate
change whether it's the continued
hangover from the pandemic
whether it's the challenges around the
cost of living and interest rates and
grocery prices and fuel prices that are
exacerbated by Russia's illegal invasion
of a Sovereign Nation there are real
challenges in the world right now
and Canadians face a choice like
everyone around the world
when the tough times come
the natural human instinct is to hunker
down
and hope the storm blows past
but that's not what Canadians do that's
not who we are I saw it throughout the
summer as I visited corners of this
country hit by wildfires some that had
rarely if ever been hit by wildfires
before every single place
where you were seeing Devastation and
lost you lost you also saw Canadians
stepping up for each other
knowing that the well-being of our
neighbors
of our entire country of our communities
matters to each of our well-beings it's
how we're hardwired as Canadians to look
out for each other to support each other
and one of the things we've learned over
the past few years is that everything is
interconnected what happens on the other
side of the world does impact us
directly
and one of the things we know more than
anything else is we all have a role to
play in making sure that the world we
are building for our kids and grandkids
is better in every way
[Applause]
but if I'm going to be honest
it's challenging sometimes to see that
there is so much hardship and Chaos all
around us
shifting geopolitical realities
backsliding democracies
challenges
to the rules and the peace and the
stability that we've seen for 75 years
in this world that has contributed to so
much prosperity and growth and
opportunities for so many
has been upended
because Vladimir Putin decided that he
wanted to invade a neighboring peaceful
Nation
he put an end to Decades of prosperity
of stability
is trying to overthrow the rules-based
order and make might right once again
we need to continue to stand strong
against that kind of thinking and it's
not just for Ukraine it's for all of us
Canadians know this is a question of
right or wrong Canadians know that yes
it is incredibly hard for Ukraine to
continue to stand against a Russian
aggression
and let's be honest it's hard for the
democracies around the world who are
there to support their citizens who are
investing for the future who are
challenged with a challenging economy
around the world to continue to step up
as Canada has with close to 9 billion
dollars in aid for Ukraine but we will
because the cost on Canadians on our
lives on our world will be so much
greater if Putin wins this war that we
will and have to stand every single day
until Ukraine wins this war
the stakes the stakes are high for
Canadians
the stakes are high for ukrainians the
stakes are high for all of us around the
world this is the moment
where we Define ourselves for the rest
of the 21st Century
did we stand up against authoritarianism
did we stand up against those who choose
to break the rules around the world do
we stand up for what is right we are
Canadian of course we're going to stand
up for what's right
and even more so
for Canadians of Ukrainian origin and
not just because of your ties to that
beautiful country
but because the strength and the courage
of the Ukrainian people in is well known
to all of us who have friends who know
community members who've seen
the extraordinary heart and spirit of
ukrainians for over a hundred years you
have helped contribute to shaping this
country settling the Prairies building
extraordinary communities and cities
contributing in arts and culture in
science in business in so many ways to
building this great country
all Canadians not just Ukrainian
Canadians all Canadians know how Fierce
and strong and steadfast the people of
Ukraine are and that is why we know you
will win this war
but you know
we Canadians are lucky to know so many
ukrainians around us
but the world has gotten to know over
the past year and a half
one Ukrainian in particular
someone
who has stood up to Putin stared him in
the face every day and stayed strong
someone who is inspired a nation and a
world
we look to Vladimir zielinski for his
leadership for his steadfastness for his
commitment for his strength
and it is an inspiration to us all not
just to ukrainians who continue
to fight for their lives and their
future
but for all of us around the world who
understand what is at stake when we see
him when we hear from him when we
understand the passion and the
leadership he shows
he will stand for what is right every
single way and he will demand the very
best not just of all ukrainians not even
just of all Canadians but of everyone
around the world who is committed to
building that better World Vladimir
as you
approach to come out
you know in my many conversations with
you over the past year and a half I've
mentioned the unwavering support
that Canada and Canadians have for you
and for Ukraine
tonight you get to feel just a little
bit of that love and support as we
welcome you here to show you that as you
are still standing for Ukraine Canada
and all Canadians stand with you for as
much as it takes for as long as it takes
place
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
lost
control
please
[Applause]
hold Canada all the people all
communities all cities
all right
this is how Unity
how Unity sounds
and I'm proud that we achieved Unity
like this
and it's so
inspiring
and it's not just inspiring it helps
others
it helps us
helps us all to become stronger
and we are stronger
[Applause]
to become stronger in our freedom to get
stronger and it moves our Unity to
Victory
Ukraine's victory
Canada's victory
peoples victory
donations
[Music]
[Applause]
the victory
will be ours and I have no doubt and I
hear
no I don't hear
the victory will be ours yeah
now I hear
[Applause]
now I hear you have no doubt
and I'm so
um
I'm happy to be
with my wife
of course lady
[Applause]
three days together
the first time
from the beginning of full-scale War
thank you just
[Applause]
[Music]
to be serious
I'm so proud that Ukraine inspires
really that ukrainians Inspire and so do
Canadian ukrainians
thank you
and I thank you all all of you that you
are active
you let others feel Ukraine's wife
the wife of Slava Ukraine
the wife of people who never surrender
we
break
[Music]
and I thank your grandfathers
and I think your grandmothers who saved
Ukrainian identity
who contributed to making Canada a great
country
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
ERS Canada gives weapons to Ukraine to
move forward to push back Russia and I
thank you for this thank you all
[Applause]
and I'm sure Canada will never lose
Ukraine and why
and the day will come when We Gather at
a similar place
in Ukraine
many people
Millions
cheering crowd blue and yellow flash
and Mabel live flesh
foreign
will say
thank you
Japanese
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Justin
Theresa thank you
[Applause]
[Music]